everything went into a kind of slow
motion
and i i just it was as if the glass was
just suspended
in air from the crash
and
it was and then i just saw
like my inception all the way up to that
moment
um
and i just saw my whole life literally
and it was
it was just this
as if i lived my life a second time but
in a moment
[Music]
hello everyone today i'm going to
continue my discussions with islamic
thinkers
or thinkers about islam i've had
previous guests uh included ayan
herzeali mustafa akhyal and muhammad
hijab i'm pleased to be speaking today
with hamza yusuf who serves as president
of zaytuna college a muslim liberal arts
college in berkeley california
he's a strong advocate of liberal
education in the classical sense
he was raised in a religiously eclectic
family attended orthodox christian
services and catholic parochial boarding
schools at the age of 18 after study the
major religions of the world he
converted to islam
he served as translator for the chief
mufti of the uae and mauritania sheikh
abdullah bin bio
i'm very pleased today to be talking to
hamza
welcome thanks for agreeing to talk to
me today
yeah thank you
so you you had a eclectic upbringing as
your bio indicated you went to orthodox
christian services were your were your
family orthodox christian
i i have two sides of the family one
were irish catholics
and then my mother was half irish half
greek so my greek grandfather who was an
archon in the greek orthodox church
he actually
had that influence on
on us so we were actually raised in his
church
but my mother was
she was actually
would have considered herself a buddhist
most of my um
upbringing
and her her mother who was an irish
woman and her
brother
my great uncle
uh were from georgia and they actually
were interested in buddhism in the 1920s
and moved out to san francisco and my
great-uncle george fields opened fields
bookstore which was the first
metaphysical bookstore on the west coast
and it specialized just in a lot of
different ways
he actually was the first publisher of
gerdjiff's works the fourth way works in
in the u.s
and it's actually still it's an online
bookstore now fields bookstore but
so it's getting more it's getting more
metaphysical all the time it's it was
once a building and now it's virtual and
yeah it's a it's a bad joke but so you
add you were exposed to a lot of
different religious ideas by the sounds
of things when you grew up um right and
how how much did you learn about
orthodox christianity
uh well i had i had
my grandfather had us take greek lessons
i went to greece i went to a greek
orthodox camp when i was 12 years old in
greece
i served the altar in the orthodox
church
so i i was reasonably involved and then
i went to catholic schools so
the orthodox tradition the catholic
tradition aren't that different even
though they split in the 11th century
over a
diphthong as gibbon points out
so when you were a kid and you were
going to services do you how can you
remember well enough to characterize
your beliefs at that time i mean
i started having trouble with the ideas
in christianity i guess when i was
probably around 12 so
i'm wondering what your reaction was as
a thinker that young
i mean i i really love the greek service
uh i love the frank incense they had
great
uh
these
uh chants that were quite beautiful
and it was very ritualistic and i i
enjoyed it i had no problem
uh going to church
i think
like many kids at that age especially
growing up
in
california
during that period because my formative
years were the late 60s and early 70s
so there was a lot of work we're a
transitional generation
there were a lot of radical changes
happening and california was kind of at
the heart of a lot of those things but
my mother did expose us to a lot of
different uh faith traditions she
actually took me
we went to synagogues we went to
buddhist song guys we went to
um
different christian iterations
um she also took me to a mosque when i
was 12 years old
in redwood city
and she was of the belief that
much of religion is is a
it's this interesting where you're born
and where you're brought up and that's
going to determine and color the way you
view the world and so she had this
idea that religions
that it's very dangerous to assume just
because you were born into something
that that's the end-all of truth and
so she was eclectic in that way
yeah so your mother was of the opinion
that i guess correct me if i'm wrong
there's a couple of aspects to religious
thinking that are interesting and
relevant given what you said i mean
one is to think of it as a set of
philosophies and beliefs that you might
hold like you would hold a set of
philosophical or even academic beliefs
and another is to become a member of a
community
a community of belief and i guess the
the
argument you might make for the latter
point is that
there's something there has to be
something that unites all of us in order
for us to be a community
and so
that proposition is hard to reconcile
with the first one which is that you
should be free to choose your beliefs as
you would a philosophy
because if everybody chooses different
beliefs then we have a hell of a time
living together and that can be a
problem
well i think that's one of the real
problems in california i mean that's
that's a very much
uh this liberal idea that everything
we're free to choose and be whatever we
want
and what do you think of that idea so
now you're much older than you were when
your mother was taking you from a place
of worship to place of worship i mean
how would you
address the problem of let's say the
conflict between freedom of choice and
religion as philosophers philosophical
belief and and religion as a as a
cultural centerpiece that unites people
well i think that
i raised my children muslim and and i
hope
that they remain in the muslim faith but
i have to acknowledge the possibility
that that might not be the case
given where we live and and the
environment
so i
i'm very committed to the islamic
tradition and i believe it to be true
and i think i ha you know i feel like
i've acquired clear and compelling
evidence for myself of its truth but i
understand the importance
of religion as a
glue that holds things together and i
think when you lose that glue in any
culture you're going to have great
problems that emerge out of
that yeah
the question starts to become very
rapidly
if
there's no shared
ground that's sacred let's say to unite
people then what in the world are they
supposed to unite around and because if
they don't unite then they exist in
conflict and so that seems and in
confusion and in anxiety and that seems
to be a
very meddlesome or what not meddlesome
very a very difficult problem
well i i think part of the problem with
you know modernity
uh
is
grappling with the fact that a lot of
these
grand narratives have broken down
largely in the 20th century i mean the
beginnings were happening already in the
17th 18th century but by the 20th
century there amongst the intelligentsia
there's a huge problem particularly in
in the west but not
only in the west i think even within the
muslim
ethos you already had these um
ideas that were going to
massively impact the culture
so it's something we're all grappling
with um it's it's an interesting time
in that um
people do have certain
abilities to look
at things in ways that perhaps growing
up in an environment
that really dictated to people
what they would believe
norms
for instance just cultural norms i mean
a lot of religion ends up being cultural
and it's it's a practice it's a cultural
practice and a lot of people don't ever
really have to deal with this in fact i
think james
charles taylor has a very interesting
book
revisiting james the variety's religious
experience and he talks about this idea
that james
looks at people who have
religion in this sanguine sense they
simply accept their religion that
they're born into and then they and then
they just live and practice that and
very often they have very solid lives in
that environment but then he talks about
and he calls those healthy people then
he talks about the sick people
who actually have to grapple
with these different phases he looks at
melancholy religious melancholy this
idea of being in a melancholic state
about the
alienation of the world about the trials
of the world the uncanniness of the
world the strangeness of it and then i
think the second he looks at the
just the
the problem of evil the
grappling with this problem of evil and
that third one is the sense of
wrong doing right that that a lot of
people feel sin yeah that's a terrible
one right now i mean
i think part of the reason why
our culture is rivened apart by
political trouble at the moment is
because issues that should be discussed
at the level of the sacred have started
to be discussed at the level of the
political and so
there's a
pervasive
accusation
against let's say western culture in
particular coming from the more radical
side of the left
claiming that
our culture or the western culture is a
tyrannical patriarchy and an oppressive
colonial enterprise and
of course all cultures are contaminated
with catastrophe and atrocity
as well
and
we actually need to know what to do
about that you know the christian
doctrine of original sin is some help in
that because
it makes the fact of
the legacy of human evil let's say
something personal but also
transpersonal at the same time right
it's part of the human condition and it
looks to me like without that
container
the guilt we have about the
arbitrariness of life and the
arbitrariness of our privileges
can start to become overwhelming and
then it can also become weaponized which
has certainly happened under at the
present
at the present time and to a dangerous
degree so you can go after people for
their privilege let's say and they do
feel guilty because
advantages and disadvantages are sort of
parsed out to some degree arbitrarily
and then you know they collapse in the
face of that onslaught and apologize and
retreat and
it just doesn't look to me like that's a
good thing at all
well it's it's not a good thing if you
don't have a religious world view that
gives meaning
to those situations for instance i mean
one of the most important aspects of the
quran i think is that it really gives
answers to these
uh inequities in the world but what uh
some of term the mystery of iniquity
and
the the quran one of the hallmarks of a
believer is uh gratefulness gratitude in
fact the word in arabic for disbeliever
means ungrateful and in great
um and and so gratitude for blessings
and then patience for trials and
tribulations
and and so
there's many verses in the quran that
talk about that we have raised some of
you over others in privilege
as a test
to show
who will be the best in action who what
are you going to do with those
privileges
how are you going to respond to those
tribulations so if you have a
a world view that actually incorporates
all of the problems in the world and
gives them meaning then it enables
people to look at them in a very
different way whereas if you remove that
you're stuck with just marxist results
yeah yeah yeah so all right let's i'm
going to go back to your conversion
because i want to understand how that
happened but i'm happy about the
direction this discussion is taking so
it seems to me that
when you realize that you're
let's say arbitrarily blessed by a
certain set of advantages
now everyone is cursed with a certain
set of disadvantages too so we can take
that into account but
so you're grateful for your privileges
let's say you regard them as a gift or
maybe you regard them as something akin
to grace
and then it seems to me that the
appropriate thing to do is attempt to
atone for them which is that
you try to make your advantages work for
you and for everyone else to the best of
your possible ability and then in some
sense you pay
you pay for
for having them that way
you're given a gift and then you do what
you can with it you do the best you can
with it and share it with people and and
and and don't try to take narrow
advantage of it you said that there are
there's islamic commentary on that kind
of idea and so maybe you could walk me
through that a bit
gratitude that's very interesting one
because
it does seem to me that
it's certainly easier on people
psychologically if they're grateful for
what they have rather than resentful and
bitter about what they don't have
and why is that associated with belief
per se let's say in islam
well
first of all the gift of being itself
i'm just the the participation in being
is a great gift and in fact that you
know the the
the german word for for guilt is
actually a sense of debt
and so the and the word in arabic for
religion is debt it means debt so we we
we have this sense of indebtedness
because we've been given so much just
just the gift of life itself is just
such an extraordinary gift
and so
religion you know in the islamic
understanding
it's
it's an act of gratitude it's you're
showing gratitude
for all that you've been given and in
fact when you get reached the highest
levels of our tradition
even the tribulations are seen as gifts
because
they're actually
ways in which we learn there's an
unveiling that happens and great
knowledge comes out of suffering great
knowledge comes out of trials and
tribulations and so
in in our tradition the highest people
are those who actually are are grateful
in trials and tribulations as well as in
blessings and gifts
because they see it all as a gift
i always think of nietzsche's comment on
it when that sort of idea comes up which
is whatever doesn't kill you makes you
stronger because
the reverse of that is whatever doesn't
make you stronger kills you and
the the problem i think that people face
when they're trying to be
sorry for tribulations is that you can
learn from them but they can also just
grind you into the ground and destroy
you and they do i mean people do die we
suffer and die and so right
in the final analysis in some sense
we're defeated by
by our mortal vulnerability and well
go ahead
go ahead i'm sorry oh well when it
visits you when a catastrophe visits you
sometimes you recover and you think well
i learned a lot but
i don't know if it's
i don't know how salutary it is in
general to
make that a general case you know what i
mean given that people suffer so much
and sometimes it seems so pointless
i know what you mean psychologically you
know
if you're suffering with something
catastrophic and you become resentful
that certainly makes it far worse
there's no doubt about that and it makes
you a danger to people around you so
it's not helpful but it's sure
understandable
well there's a there's a very
interesting
uh
do you know jacques lesser
that he wrote a book called and there
was light
he was that he was a he was a french
resistance fighter
and he wrote he wrote this very
interesting autobiography but one of the
things that happened to him when he was
eight years old he was in school and he
and some some kid accidentally bumped
into him and he fell onto the desk and
he ended up losing both his eyes
uh in that in that event one of the
things that he said that really struck
me when i read that was
he said that he was very grateful to god
that that happened to him as a child and
then he gave two reasons the first
reason was he said a child's body is
still supple and they're still coming
into their body so to lose his sight at
that time
was was very useful because somebody
who's older
if they lose their their sight it's very
difficult for them to readjust to the
world
that was the first reason for his
gratitude but the second reason was he
said a child does not
question
injustice of events it doesn't think
that events are unjust it can see
injustice from people
but events just happen to children and
they don't
really put that valence on it as
something why did god do this to me and
as somebody who
worked in pediatrics for a period
as a as a registered nurse
it always struck me you know the parents
were always devastated but the children
were in these uh quite extraordinary
states and lesoran says that it's only
when
parents
actually
give the child that idea
of of that something's wrong here will
they will they do that but normally
children just simply accept that and i
think that has a lot due to what christ
said that you know that the way you come
to god is like like children and i think
that's that's at the heart of it it's
just accepting because
the sense of entitlement that human
beings have is overwhelming this idea
that we're all entitled to health that
we're entitled to
uh
wealth that we're entitled to
uh for things to work out that's it's
not the way life is designed it never
was and it's something the ancients
really understood and i think modern
people have a really difficult time
grappling with this because they're not
well spiritually and pre-modern people i
think
generally were much healthier uh
spiritually and certainly all of these
pre-modern civilizations understood that
life was trial and tribulation first and
foremost i mean the quran actually says
that it's god who created death and life
to try you just to show to reveal who is
the best of you in actions and so
accepting that is is a really great um
is a really great gift and and if
anything i mean that's the gift of grace
one of one of the great um
scholars of our tradition
said
that he was so burdened
his name was ibn al-qaeda he was an
egyptian but he said he was so burdened
with with uh his self and he went to
this teacher
um abraham
and he
when he came in he said to him
all of the world is just four conditions
and each of those conditions has a
response
the first condition is blessing and the
response is gratitude the second
condition is tribulation and the
response is patience the third condition
is obedience and the response is
humility
is to see that the grace in that
obedience and the and the fourth uh
circumstance is sinfulness and the
response is repentance
so that's a taxonomy for life itself
so
repentance that's an interesting one
because
one of the things our culture seems to
have a difficult time with too is
allowing people to repent this
social media in particular seems to have
put a lot of advantage in the hands of
accusers and attackers and so people are
mobbed or cancelled or so forth
and it
it's a rare person who doesn't have
something
in their past let's say that might make
them the target of such treatment
but
and that means that's a universal
problem as well and it isn't obvious
that we have a mechanism for repentance
and reintegration that's nearly as
powerful as the mechanisms we've
developed for accusation and exclusion
i guess i guess i should throw a
question on to the end of that no no
that's fine and i thought well you look
like you were still thinking about it
well
i'm just i guess what i'm wondering is
what what how would you characterize the
islamic view of repentance and
people talk a lot about the necessity to
forgive hey and i've thought that
through fairly
thoroughly as a clinical psychologist
because
forgiveness isn't
in my estimation isn't just a a simple
act of letting something go because
if something's bothering you it's not
that easy to let it go if if you have a
problem with someone
there's a gospel story about that you're
not supposed to go pray in the church if
you have a fight with pending with your
brother an unresolved fight with your
brother you straighten that out first
my experience as a clinician has been
that
for forgiveness to take place generally
speaking there has to be a discussion
between the parties involved or at least
a very
lengthy session of thought by the person
who's aggravated and offended to take
apart the offense to
detail out its characteristics to
separate the wheat from the chaff
to understand exactly what went wrong to
negotiate an agreement moving forward
that such things won't happen like
there's there seems to be this continual
interplay between judgment and
forgiveness in something that's
that really is
akin to forgiveness and for you to
repent
about something that you've done it
seems to me that the same process of
discrimination has to take place is
why did something wrong well exactly
what did you do wrong and exactly why
did you do it and why do you think it
was wrong and what do you think that you
should have done better and how are you
going to conduct yourself in the future
and
two questions then one is that in
keeping with your understanding of what
constitutes repentance and second
what are the islam how would you
characterize islamic thought on that
particular matter
well i is the islamic tradition like the
jewish and christian before
have this idea of repentance
um
the the in the greek new testament word
metanoia is a beautiful word because
it's really you know the idea of
transforming the mind changing the mind
in arabic it's the idea of turning
and and so there's there's this idea
that the heart turns towards
disobedience and then it has to turn
back towards obedience
and so
that that turning then one of the names
of god is tawa in arabic which means the
off turning the one who turns back when
you turn to god god turns to you
uh and so this idea
of turning back to god is very important
and the prophet muhammad sallallahu is
you know he taught us actually to do
this at least 70 times a day
so muslims as a as a practice actually
ask forgiveness
preferably at least 70 times a day just
saying a stuff that a lot it's something
that we do as a spiritual practice and
part of the reason why we pray five
times a day the prophetic son was once
asked about a man who lives next to a
river and he goes into it and he washes
five times a day he said do you think
that you would see any
filth on him and they said no and he
said that's what prayer is
it's like washing it's like bathing in a
river five times a day i mean one of the
reasons we do lustration with uh water
is a ritual purification so we wash our
face we purify
our our eyes and our and our tongue we
actually rinse our mouth with water
before we pray and and then we wash our
hands our limbs and then our feet and
and the idea is about really
turning back to god because these gifts
that we've been given these seven limbs
that we have been given are gifts from
god that should be used in good and so
the idea you know it's interesting that
in in old english in
new testament greek and hebrew and
arabic the word for sin is an archery
term
which means to to miss them it's the
mark yes right
and and so this idea
you know uh
uh
this this great basketball player was
once asked what he thought about when he
missed a shot he said too far too short
too much to the left too much to the
right that that that's what sin is it's
it's basically we there's omission or
commission
we did too much of something too little
of something
to deviate to the left or the right and
so it's finding that sweet spot of
obedience
uh and being in a state of ritual purity
and then we have conditions so in order
for a repentance to be
sound
uh it has to be sincere the person
actually has to have a sincere
repentance it has to be done
like if you're actually right and
sincere
sincere means
to recognize the wrongdoing and to
strive not to do it again with that yeah
definition of sincerity
i yeah
sincerity the arabic word for sincerity
is related to the word for purity and
untainted
and and so it's done without ulterior
motives because sometimes people will
will ask forgiveness and they just don't
want to be cut out of the will
right that's an instrumental forgiveness
right exactly
okay so you you talked this is quite
interesting so
you
wandered through territory there that
linked up
physical disgust and contamination with
psychological and spiritual disgust and
contamination and
it's my experience with people that a
good number of them feel guilty and out
of sorts and alienated a good amount of
the time
and you say well
this that sin means to miss the mark and
the reason they feel alienated at least
in principle is because they're missing
the mark and of course then the question
is well what exactly is the mark
and it seems to me that
you you you drew a parallel between
prayer and washing
and
both of them are to remove disgusting
contaminants let's say
and
one of the signs that someone has a
conscience although conscience can be
over
active and that can be a problem is that
they are laboring under
a burden of self-disgust and
self-contempt and they do feel their
moral transgressions as something
contemptuous and beneath them and base
and so
this
prayer upward let's say to a higher
aim
and a reminder of that which in your
tradition you're doing at least five
you're doing five times a day
that's a constant attempt to set
yourself on the right track so that your
aim can be
true
it's a reorientation it's a
reorientation yeah do you think
even physiologically speaking it seems
likely that there's a relationship
between
the the idea of decontaminating yourself
by becoming clean and spiritually
decontaminating yourself with reference
to something to a higher
aim well i think people do like you said
and i'm sure you've seen this a lot in
clinical practice
people do feel unwell
and they feel sick and and
modern psychology attempts to give them
you know the anti-christic formula is to
say
unlike christ who said go and sin no
more you know the the anti-christic
formula is to say go and there's no more
sin so i'm just going to remove that bag
of bricks that you're you're right
you absolutely can't do that as a
therapist you know it's not it's not
even technically possible i don't
believe because
sometimes you might see somebody who has
an
overactive super ego you know if you
want to speak in a freudian sense and
there are people who punish themselves
extremely harshly and then you might say
their sin is
excessive use of force on their self in
relationship to their transgressions
and that's and then maybe you help
once you understand that with them you
help them
understand
how
it might be possible to use the lightest
touch possible that still
serves the purpose
which is a good
limit idea with regards to the
administration of punishment towards
yourself right
minimal necessary force that's a good
common law tradition it's a good
psychological tradition but as a
therapist certainly can't
alleviate people's guilt arbitrarily by
telling them you know well there's
nothing really there to worry about they
have to do all that thinking through
that themselves
and this very interested in this
relationship between
disgust physical
the physical sense of disgust and the
psychological sense of disgust
and the notion that
i mean it's one form of prayer you might
say in christianity is baptism that be
in some ways the most fundamental form
of prayer it's rebirth in the christian
tradition
and it involves obviously it involves
the use of water sometimes a full body
immersement and so there's a notion of
purification there
it seems to me that in the modern world
people don't know what to do with the
sense they have that they're bad
right it impli implies that there's a
good because you wouldn't feel bad if
there wasn't a good but it isn't obvious
what the good is that should be aimed at
well that's the difference between real
and apparent goods and so i mean one of
the most important things about any true
religious tradition is it has to
distinguish between real and apparent
goods because the reason they use that
archery term is that people are always
looking for a good
it's just if you don't have the
discernment to distinguish between a
real and a apparent good
and so discernment is very important
what what the quran calls for in fact
the quran itself is it terms itself as a
foreign a discernment a standard by a
criteria
a criterion that you can judge actions
we have a great um
book in virtue ethics called mizan
al-amman the standard or the criterion
of action
which
uses
definitely some of the motifs that are
in the nicomachean ethics but
it's it's this interesting amalgam
between that hellenistic uh tradition
and then
infused with the quranic theological
virtues you know i i wanted to just add
i forgot to uh mention that the other
two
um
necessary conditions for a sound
uh repentance one of them was that you
made a firm intention not to go back to
that action
and then the the fourth one is that if
it involved a wrong of another person
then you had to ask them forgiveness
you had to go and you had to like if you
stole then you had to actually give the
money back right if you could if you
didn't know who you stole it from you
actually give it in charity in that
person's name
right so that's part of discharging that
debt
the debt exactly right and it's
certainly the case that people seem to
feel innately i would say something akin
to a psychological debt
and that well on that we discussed
already the fact that that can be
weaponized you know by by accusations of
arbitrary privilege and so forth and so
it is it isn't easy to know what to do
with that so let's go back just for a
moment to
to
your religious upbringing
tell me what led up to your conversion
if you would and and why did you move
away from christianity or buddhism or
all the things that you were exposed to
when you were well i i had i had i was
in a head-on collision
and survived a a car accident that the
california highway patrol said i
shouldn't have survived
and i had i had what they call a
near-death experience i got very
interested
in what happens after you die i realized
that i could have very easily
transitioned
and so i was very interested in what
happens after death i actually went and
met with dr raymond moody who wrote the
books on life after life and
uh
he did a lot of the work with near-death
um people that had had can i ask you
what happened in your near-death
experience
i think was pretty classic you know i i
definitely saw
my i went into a very different
um
[Music]
spatial temporal state where i
that i just
everything went into a kind of slow
motion
and i i just it was as if the glass was
just suspended
in air from the crash
and
it was and then i just saw
like my inception all the way up to that
moment
um
and i just saw my whole life literally
and it was
it was just this
as if i lived my life a second time but
in a moment
that that was the experience and why
that
what did that do for you that experience
what how did well one one
one it made me you know at the time i
was a senior in high school my my
probably biggest interests were baseball
and
and other things
but uh
music was certainly a big interest
my family i come from a family of
musicians
so um
i think what it did is it made me really
think about death in a very deep way and
if you've ever seen
um
there's a there's a film about a man who
who's in a a
plane crash
and uh and then he survives the plane
crash and is a man who had a lot of
fears but he comes out of it jeff
bridges is the person
and and he's like looking at his hands
and am i alive or am i dead i was in
that state for about two weeks
it was very it was a very strange state
to be in uh and that got me interested
in in
what religions say about after death
and
so i decided to study all the world
religions
just from that perspective
and
the one that really really resonated and
struck me as having
a very very powerful
description was the islamic tradition
and i actually ended up
ironically i ended up writing
in the uh the study of quran
which was published by uh
harper i ended up writing the essay on
death in the quran which is how i
actually became muslim so it was a very
interesting serendipitous
uh
so walk me through that so
okay so you just about died how old were
you
17.
yeah so i've i've there have been
studies showing for example that
if you have someone i remember this
study if you have someone jump off a
bungee cord
watching a digital clock
the clock goes slower for them
subjectively so if you subject people to
a tremendous amount of stress then time
slows down and i suspect the
neurophysiological reason for that is
that
when you're in a tremendous crisis your
body floods itself with the hormones and
neurochemicals probably mostly dopamine
that are necessary for you to act
extraordinarily quickly and it's
extremely energy intensive to do that so
you can't do it all the time
but maybe we can snap ourselves into a
psychophysiological state where we're a
hundred times faster than we would
normally be for some very finite amount
of time
i'm not trying to
what would you say reduce this to a
physiological expert well that's that's
a very common reductionist approach yeah
yeah yeah well
it's an experience and experience that i
mean you you can look at the soft the uh
the hard drive aspect of it but the
software's the mystery yeah i'm
definitely not trying to remove the
phenomenological significance you know
because that would be foolish and
and even those those explanations are
only attempts at understanding uh
phenomenon that we really don't have
access to because
cause and effect is a very difficult
thing to it tonight
it certainly is yeah and and that kind
of explanation doesn't account for all
the near-death experience phenomena
either
but
i mean i mean you asked you asked me how
you know that that got me thinking a lot
about death right irrespective of
whatever the neurochemical phenomena
that were happening within my body that
experience that phenomenological
experience
had a
existential
right effect on me that was very
powerful and
and i decided that i really wanted to
know if i could have died in that moment
which was very possible i wanted to know
what what if anything happens and if
something happens
how do you prepare for that like what
you know it
if we're on if we're genuinely on the
doors of infinity
then we should take this time that we
have very seriously to prepare to go
through that door and that's what
existentially that's what happened to me
i wanted to know
if i can go through that door at any
moment as a 17 year old i could have
done it
now as a
64 year old it's possible that i could
do it today or tomorrow the next day
what type of preparation do i need
why did you why do you think that you
derived the conclusion that
it was something that you needed to be
prepared for
well i think that yeah i i just think
that's
a kind of
uh
i just think it's common sense you know
like
i mean preparing for dinner
it's interesting
when i worked when i worked in critical
care what became very clear to me
some people
seem to be ready for death and other
people are definitely not ready for
death
and i and i can see the difference i saw
the difference you know i my both my
parents died i was
uh
with both my parents
and and i could see you know
i mean my mother had an incredible
transition
and i think my mother was fully ready to
go into the next world i don't think a
lot of people are ready i think a lot of
people are very afraid of death
and i think that's something that
one of the gifts of religion
is it does remove that fear not
necessarily the act of of dying because
obviously that's a very intense
uh experience especially for those of us
who have seen that
in people who die
um
but
the the the transition into the next
world is something the quran says
it's something to be looked forward to
it's not something to fear but but it's
also islam is not a death cult the
prophet allah said
don't desire to die but ask god for a
long life
and and he said
that none of you should ever desire
death
you should desire to have a long life
because you have more time to do more
good and the more good you do the more
you accrue
in terms of preparation for that
transition and what do you think it
means to be prepared versus not prepared
to die
to be in a good state i think to be
like if if you're in a state of
repentance if you're if whatever you've
done in the past if you've really
uh repented for any of the wrongs that
you've done and there's major wrongs
there's minor wrongs uh there's there's
the peccadillos and then there's the
those mortal sins that that
that are recognized for what they are
things that literally will cause death
to the soul the wages of sin is death
so i think being in a good state being
prepared being ready to make that
transition is very important and i think
in many ways a lot of uh the practices
that we do
in our tradition are in preparation for
death in fact
if you look at just the five prayers
uh the very first prayer that we do when
we wake up the prophetic gave us a
prayer that i did this morning when i
first came into consciousness which says
praise be to the the one who brought me
back to life
because death in the quran is uh sleep
and the quran is seen as a little death
and so it's every morning we have a
resurrection
that's to remind us of the the
resurrection on the day of judgment and
then the very first thing that we do is
we wash and then we pray that's that's
the first thing that muslims do when
they wake at dawn when the sun before
the sun comes up
and then before we go to bed that's the
last thing that we do we make a prayer
oh god if you take my soul in my sleep
have mercy on it and if you let me live
another day then make me amongst the
righteous and protect me these are all
prayers that our prophet sam did every
single day and then on on friday we have
a communal prayer which is is the day of
gathering which is related to the day of
judgment where you all stand before god
and then also in ramadan we fast so we
were giving up the pleasures of life
during the daylight hours for a month
and then the end of it is a celebration
of making it through that month
uh hopefully with as little sin as
possible and then we have the the
the uh the prayer the the poor tax which
is to do good to others from the good
that you've been given and then we have
the hajj which is really a preparation
for death because you're making this
pilgrimage
you're you you get into white clothes
which is the sh to
symbolize the shroud and then you stand
on the plane of of arafat like the day
of judgment which symbolizes
that all of humanity is going to stand
in a non-spatial non-temporal sense is
going to stand before their creator and
be judged for what they did so we
believe in a day of judgment
so when
you were
sixteen or seventeen how old were you
when you had the card
so then you became
interested in the issue of death and the
meaning of death and the idea of
preparation for death and you read
widely throughout the world's religions
and
you said that islam in particular struck
your fancy
when did you convert how old were you
18.
okay so that's that's that's was that a
radical move as far as your family was
concerned
um
you know my dad the first thing he did
he went to gibbon and re-read the
section on the rise of islam
my dad was a professor of philosophy
so
you know he was a lapsed catholic um
probably the most well-read person i've
ever met in the western canon
i think he was intrigued he didn't
really understand it
my mom was fine with it
she thought great you know you found a
path
that's how she viewed it but both my
father both my parents ended up uh
making the declaration of faith before
they died so
my father read gazali
and uh ended up becoming muslim
so what was it about specifically about
the islamic treatment of death in the
afterlife compared to say the christian
or jewish
treatment
one the quran is
the scent of death is on every page of
the quran so it's
it's definitely a very very
it's a death reminder and not in a
negative way there's this tension
release that happens in the quran
i was once in a in a hotel
and and and in london
and there was a guy across from me
reading the quran english translation
and drinking a heineken beer which was
very interesting and uh so i you know i
was dressed in western clothes and i
just asked him how are you finding that
book he said this book is very
interesting
and and i said in what way and he said
you know it's just tension release
tension release
and
i i said wow you got that on the first
reading that's very impressive
because it's you know it'll tell you
about all the the wages of sin but then
it'll tell you about the blessings of of
obedience and and
and turning to god and repenting and
answering the call of the prophets that
perennial call that the prophets to shun
false idols including the idol of the
self
to turn away from uh the vanities of
life the vein appetites uh that are of
no use for you yeah
earlier you talked about apparent and
real
uh goods
and so you're you're referring to that
in a sense here again and
making the presumption that there is a
hierarchy of values and that some things
should be pursued in preference to
others and
this is something that the modern west
has great difficulty formalizing and
accepting although people
suffer
for it regardless of their understanding
of it
when when you
are thinking about turning your eyes
heavenward or getting your aim straight
or
obedience to god
what do you think what does that mean to
you conceptually and what does it mean
practically in your life
well i mean practically it means staying
within
the what we call the hadoo the quran
calls the limits that god has set on us
so we have certain limits that are set
on us and those limits are to protect us
so everything in the islamic tradition
according to our al-qazali and others
everything in our tradition is to
protect one of six things
to protect religion itself
to protect uh human intellect reason so
like the prohibition of alcohol is to
protect
human reason to protect life sorry life
is the next to protect life to protect
human reason to protect property
uh which is really what richard weaver
called the last metaphysical right
standing you know the right to property
um and and then to protect um
family
and then to protect human dignity so
those six things there's no ruling in
islam that isn't addressing one of those
six preservations
and so
everything that we do is
is for for the that that's the
the way in which we try to live our
lives so
family being good to family taking care
of those in need around you first and
foremost charity begins at home and then
extending to those closest to you so
islam is is antagonistic to socialism
it's antagonistic to any kind of
collectivist philosophy but it does
recognize that each one of us should be
giving something back
to okay so
i'm going to let you go through that
again but you said something there
that's very interesting to me
you said that islam is antagonistic to a
collectivist philosophy
can you tell me why why
either why that's true or why you
believe it to be true
well first and foremost the quran itself
because the quran if you look at it it's
a book of individuals going against
groups that are insane
i mean every single story in the quran
is an individual who goes up against a
group and the group says burn him throw
him in the fire stone him
so
that you know it's pretty clear from the
quran that the group is not
necessarily a good thing and the prophet
muhammad said
master yourselves so that you don't
become yes people that when people do
good you do good and when they do bad
you do bad but but be so that when
people do good you're with them and when
they do bad you refrain from their evil
so
it's very important for
you know in one of the tragedies
obviously is that any group goes into
group think i mean
you know this is an area you're much
more familiar with than i am but
group think is a is a huge problem and i
think the quran addresses that problem
constantly by showing that you have to
stand up against the group
because the group as nietzsche pointed
out you know that
insanity or madness is unusual amongst
individuals but it seems to be the norm
amongst groups i mean i i think
kierkegaard said kierkegaard said that
the the group was untruth
he said even if a truth a natural truth
is claimed by a group instantly it
becomes untruth merely because the group
has acclaimed it
because because truth for him was
individual in the same sense that you're
describing do you think that's
a akin to the jewish emphasis on the
prophetic tradition
i absolutely yeah and but i also think
that that the islamic tradition does
emphasize the importance of community
and the importance of sociability
you know this idea that um that we are
gregarious human beings that we're we're
people that
we need
society
to to to fully realize ourselves and
it's the rare individual that can be the
anchorite you know as aristotle said
it's it's either a beast or a god that
can live alone but
um
you know it's a very difficult thing
there are people that can do it and and
i've known a few
uh people like that and we and we do
have a tradition the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him said that
towards the latter days it's better to
avoid all the groups
and that's in a sound tradition because
he said the groups would be astray okay
so let me ask you a question that's
always put to people who are religious
how do you differentiate religious
belief from
idolatry from from ideological belief
i i don't personally i don't think
they're the same by the way but i'm
curious about you know because it's
pretty easy for someone just to say well
you talk about standing up against the
collective but you christians you jews
you islamic types you're part of a mob
just like everybody else and why does
your particular mob view reign supreme
in your view why isn't that just another
idol in the desert just like the rest of
them what makes it different do you
think
well i think that you can you know as
the bard said to his idolatry to make
the service greater than the god it's
very easy to turn a religion into an
idol
and uh and and i think
there are i think that's what the new
atheists subject to right is that the
fact that religious belief can be maybe
it can be hijacked for instrumental and
dogmatic purposes extremely yeah as if
as if ideology
isn't as if anything can't go wrong well
there is that yes yeah and so i mean i
don't know like i think
you know these great the the 20th
century is is a largely irreligious
century in in the western hemisphere and
just look what these uh it non-religious
ideologies at this point has been
pointed out by many people yes one one
of the things about
you know
are you familiar with errol colnoy
k-o-l-n-a-i
no i'm i'm not k-o
yeah n-a-i so he was a hungarian jew who
converted to catholicism but he wrote a
very interesting paper in 1951 called
the three writers of the apocalypse he
also wrote a book about nazi germany in
1938 and really uh i think
really just tell me his name again errol
colnoy
k-o-l-e-n-a-i arrow k-a-u-r-e-l
yeah oh anyway a-e-u-r-a-u-r-a-l
a-u-r-e-l
okay colonoid k-o-l so anyway he wrote
up he wrote an essay called the three
writers of the apocalypse
and he identified three totalitarian
ideologies uh he said the first two
fascism and communism were easy to
recognize but he said that the the real
danger dangerous one was progressive
liberalism because the seeds of
totalitarianism were not seen uh very
easily it was something that could be
missed
so
if well if i had to choose let's say if
i had to choose the leader of a country
let's say an arbitrarily powerful leader
it seems to me that it would be a better
choice for me to select someone who
believes that he's beholden to something
above and beyond himself
than to choose someone who doesn't have
that belief at all
right and that seems to me
regardless of what you might say
philosophically or even scientifically
about the utility of religious belief or
the validity of religious belief
the notion that you could be the leader
of a powerful country and not be
serving something that wasn't only you
seems to be a real problem with a
let's say a stringently atheistic
philosophy because well why wouldn't you
just serve you in a position like that
well and and and you would need
generally it's the religious traditions
that understand service is for not just
the self i mean we we obviously have to
serve ourselves just to live
but service to others and that's why
political leaders in the pre-modern
world it was always understood that they
had the greatest burden of
self-discipline
that that they had a greater burden of
self-discipline than everybody else for
that
greater power and right greater
temptation
and so and so the religious traditions i
mean the you know the pre-modern world
understood very well in whatever
civilization you were in they understood
very well that the the central problem
that human beings are confronted with
uh is their self
and and that the modern water world has
completely lost that idea that you had
to
uh master yourself hence
hence you know one of the things that uh
confucius said is that um
you know that study without thinking
uh is is blindness
but thinking without study is dangerous
right and so if you don't study
those things that are that will equip
you to deal with the self
and that's why in our tradition and in
all the great traditions but in the
islamic tradition
the study of the self psychology the
nufs it's termed in arabic it was
central to our tradition to
understanding the nature of the self to
understanding the machinations of the
self the tricks of the self how the
steps
and and and to understand those things
so that you could you could learn to
discipline them i mean this gets back to
you know imam markazari uses the idea of
the sage the dog and the pig which
obviously you know plato would have said
the charioteer and and the two horses
uh it's the same idea but you know the
pig is the uh the concupiscent soul the
the dog is the harassable soul and then
the sage is the is the rational soul if
if the sage is in charge then things
will turn out well but if if if you
allow the pig or the dog to take over in
our culture you know the pig
has definitely
it's the pig seems to really be having a
field day
right the uh the pig is doing very well
you know
the dog is not doing too bad either well
it's interesting because exactly and i
think the world is split you know vinnie
brown back in the 70s saw this
north-south problem of of i mean he
didn't term it like this but but i i see
it as as the pig and the dog
you know i mean if you if if you have
affluence on on one spectrum and you
have
real um
uh just diminishing of goods just of
human goods on the other you're going to
create a lot of resentment and and so
that's a huge problem that we have so
this idea you know frost talked about
fire and ice some say the world will end
in fire some saying ice
he was talking about this the dog and
the pig from what i've tasted of desire
i hope with those who favor fire
right in other words
the world's end will come from the pig
just wreaking havoc
and and uh but then he said but if it
happened here
twice i think of you know so let me ask
for
yeah
sorry please finish that ice is yeah
yeah that that hate is also great and
will suffice you know that that the
erasable can do it as well it's one or
the other it's either going to be fire
or ice okay but
that's in the absence that's in the
absence
of
the uh you know
the the sage that's in the absence of
wisdom and wisdom is a word that's not
often heard
yes well
i've had a lot of discussions with
people who regard themselves as
explicitly atheistic
and
it seems to me that
a lot of the discussion about religious
belief in atheism misses the mark let's
put it that way
i tend to think of
god if i'm thinking about the idea of
god psychologically
i tend to think about something akin to
a hierarchy of values and that's
very much similar to
the proposition that you're putting
forward with the metaphor of the pig and
the dog and the sage
that there are some values that are
higher than others
and so i would say
i think that's psychologically true that
there are some values higher than others
i mean we tend to put our families
before ourselves for example
and we tend to have a sense that we
would
we would like to be good people
i i use this this
illustration of the relationship between
values imagine that you're
making a meal
you might ask yourself well what are you
doing say you're cutting up vegetables
okay so you're moving your hand back and
forth that's not abstract at all that's
where the mind meets the body you're
moving your hand back and forth to cut
the vegetables
to put them in the pot
to cook a good dinner
to be a good father
to be a good husband
to be a good
citizen to be a good person
so you're doing all those things at the
same time right and
each of the more particular things nests
in the broader value
and the broader a value is the more
other values depend on it and also maybe
the broader value is the more other
people can be united within it
and so i think you can come to a
technical understanding of something
like
depth of value
and then it seems to me that the
religious proposition is that there is
an ultimate value that's either at the
pinnacle or at the base depending on how
you conceptualize the metaphor
and that that
ultimate value
is expressed in religious terminal
terminology as the absolute the
ineffable absolute as the god that's
supposed to be served
and in some sense it has to remain
ineffable and beyond comprehension
because otherwise it turns into an idol
and so what you do in a religious sense
is posit
an ultimate ideal subordinate
subordinate yourself to it regarded as
something that you can only ever
approximate to even in principle
and organize all the other virtues
and defeat the faults in relationship to
that highest order value
and that's more like
i think part of the reason that
religious traditions insist upon faith
isn't
it's not faith it's not the faith that
the scientists
the scientists types
criticize which is sort of like an
empirical statement about the structure
of objective reality it's more like
the notion that there is a hierarchy of
values and that there's something that
has to be absolute ineffable and
ultimately uniting at the apex that we
should be subservient to you know that
we should consider all our behaviors in
relationship to
and
and and so that's
you know there's not a metaphysics there
in some sense because i i'm not saying
anything about the final nature of that
absolute value
right that's an ontological question i
don't feel
qualified to answer it
but
i can't see how there can be an absence
of an absolute unifying value that's
super ordinate to all other values
without society degenerating into
conflict without people becoming anxious
and confused and aimless without without
the consequences being that we all miss
the mark
so i guess i'd like your comments about
that
yeah i don't think god's something that
we posit um i think and i also certainly
don't think god is a value
um i think that god
that we respond
to
uh god and and that god makes a call and
that call is through these
intermediaries and and the prophets the
quran says in in the chapter called the
be that there is no nation that hasn't
been given warners that say shun idols
and worship god
and and so i wasn't trying to i wasn't
trying to what would you say
reduce god to a human value
because but a lot of people do i mean i
know i know that i don't understand that
of viewing god yeah well that's why i
insisted upon the ineffability
well
yeah however you want to uh state that i
mean i
for for for us for abrahamic people in
particular
god that we respond to god god makes a
call and that calls through the prophets
and the prophets are surprisingly
consistent unlike philosophers who the
student invariably rejects uh the master
you know uh plato is a friend but the
truth is a greater friend whereas the
prophets are extraordinarily consistent
in their messaging
um that there is a god that that god
demands that that you you live within
the limits that god has set as your
creator i mean one of the things that
atheists to me uh that the atheist
you know there's a definition of health
um
which which looks at the physical the
emotional and the spiritual uh george
vitholka is a great uh
health practitioner from greece
um said that atheism is really one of
the
most serious uh
signs of ill health
because it's a denial of your
creativeness
that you have to really be unhealthy to
do that so he saw it as a deep spiritual
sickness to deny your creator
whether that creator is is uh
is a personal creator is the next stage
that you're going to to have to ask
yourself but to deny your creativeness
um is is something quite extraordinary
by saying there's no creator
so how do you
deal with the challenges
the hypothetical challenges presented to
the notion of created human beings
the conflict between that and
modern evolutionary theory as a modern
thinker
i mean the catholics have accepted
evolutionary theory but that's my
understanding of the situation yeah
guided evolution guided evolution not
this idea of randomness i mean to get
the best response to that is uh i think
robert frost's poem called accidentally
on purpose that would be my answer
somebody can if they're interested can
google it look at it but
you know i this idea that
randomness um
that created this i i just i won't buy
that and if if uh if if they want to say
it's because i don't understand
evolution that's fine i'll accept that
well i talked to sam harrison richard
dawkins recently i'm going to release
the discussion i had with dawkins and
the randomness argument's an interesting
one because
it's the variability between people
that's in some sense random but
sexual selection plays an awfully
powerful force in evolutionary
biology and sexual selection is anything
but random and so to me i see the action
of consciousness
in in perhaps in the ultimate sense
operating not least through the
mechanism of sexual selection
so the selection mechanisms aren't
random even if the variation might be
generated in part randomly
and it seems to me that there's
something there that would
reconcile the
relationship in modern biology between
the spirit and the matter spirit and
matter let's say
so because consciousness calls matter
into being in some real sense
so
well consciousness also for us is a
spiritual phenomenon it's not it's not a
material phenomenon
and and uh you know the the ancients
said that the the one who denies the
soul that you'd have to determine him an
idiot uh it's you know they really saw
it as a kind of absurdity
to deny the existence of a soul because
it's so clear if anybody's ever seen a
corpse
that something's
very profoundly missing
so
what let's go back to practicalities
with regards to islam and also i'd be
interested in
you you said that you chose
so i want to know what it following the
islamic faith has done for your life
personally
how has it helped you put yourself
together
and also
i'm interested in again
why you found the islamic tradition
preferable let's say to the orthodox
tradition that you did you did enjoy the
rituals that were part of that at least
so let's deal with practical issues
first so
well i yeah
um
in terms of of uh
of why i chose islam i mean i'm not
completely convinced that i chose islam
i mean in some ways islam chose me as
well
so
it's you know guidance is a very strange
thing for people like i
saw an inevitability when i look back on
what happened i saw an inevitability
of of my
embracing islam i had some very
interesting experiences that
could be term in mystical or however
you want to determine them but uh
the the tradition itself what what
struck me was one i got to keep all of
the prophets that i i believed in
already and i added in addition
uh what we consider to be the final
prophet and just as
very often christians marvel at how jews
miss jesus
muslims also marvel at how
christians and jews miss muhammad
although to be fair to the jews they do
acknowledge the prophet
uh as a providential force and and they
do acknowledge him as a a noah hiddick
messenger preparing the way for the
the coming of the messiah so they do
recognize that he was a providential
force at least the great um
if you read george kohler's book on
jewish theology as a chapter on judaism
in islam and certainly the great
father of orientalism
uh ignites goals at her he actually said
that he felt that islam was the only
religion that somebody of a
philosophical bent could actually accept
and he wanted to to to really bring in
the gift of philosophy into judaism that
had been
that the muslims
had so richly participated in in fact
you know there's an argument that just
as judaism prepared the way
uh for christianity it was islam that
prepared the way for uh for a
philosophical western christendom
because if you look at the transmission
of all of that knowledge that comes into
europe it's quite extraordinary i mean
saint thomas aquinas who's 13th century
he dies in 1274 and yet he's the doctor
of the church just look at the number of
times he quotes muslims
i mean he calls average the commentator
so i think
islam
you know one of the beauties of the
religion to me is that you'll find
whatever you're looking for in it
i mean islam
you you it has a a very simple theology
that anybody can understand in sort of
the chapter that says say god is is
unique
uh god is
completely independent
god neither gives birth nor was god born
and there's nothing like god so it gives
you a very simple
uh theology that anybody can understand
and yet embedded in that simplicity is
an extraordinary complexity that
actually created a metaphysical
tradition
that western scholars have spent their
lifetime studying people like already
correanor or somebody it's it's like uh
maxine rodents and
uh not maxine rodison but uh uh the
great uh catholic uh theologian and and
metaphysician jacques maratin you know
recognize the genius of people like
al-halaj and things so within the
islamic tradition there's just an
extraordinary spectrum you can spend
your entire life and have a satisfying
life and i know people that have done
this just mastering
their ascensions of the quran and the
the actual
oral
expression of the quran through the the
rules of tajweed
you can spend your life studying
exegesis you can spend your life
studying prophetic tradition you can
spend your life studying the great
mystics of islam we have the best poets
in the world
we also have the best architecture i
mean there's nothing like the taj mahal
or the alhambra palace
and even western architecture if you
read
stealing from the saracens she shows how
some of the finest western architecture
was basically taken from the islamic
civilization including notre dame in in
paris so you can find incredible i know
people that just uh
came to islam through music
i mean i know some
really uh professional musicians that
fell in love with arabic music which led
them into
uh muslim culture
people that um
love
just i mean one of the most interesting
things about islam
is
it is a truly universal religion in that
you can go from indonesia to california
and find all of these different
expressions of the same central truths
of islam with their own local colorings
so the west african muslims are not like
the middle eastern muslims the middle
eastern muslims are not like the indian
muslims and you have people like uh
you know one of the great um
impressionist painters
of
of sweden i think he's actually
considered a national treasure
in in sweden but uh his his painting's
hanging the museum there he became
muslim
uh in in jail in uh
in um
for for actually he he shot a a matador
because he was raised but his father was
a veterinarian and he shot a matador um
because he was so horrified that they
were bringing bull fighting into france
and there was such an uproar that they
actually released him
but when he was in jail he befriended an
algerian who
used to recite quran all the time and he
ended up becoming muslim
and uh and then studying in egypt and
then going back to uh
to his native land he died in spain
but extraordinary individuals so you
have people like that you have people
that
anybody can find what they're looking
for and and that is the power of the
faith i think is that it is truly a
universal faith and i think one of the
things that western people tend to do
one they don't recognize that it's a
western faith because it is it's part of
the abrahamic phase it was in spain for
centuries it's been in eastern europe
for centuries
um and even istanbul which is the great
capital of islam for centuries is half
in europe and happened in in
in the east and that's why it really
bridges these two worlds
and so there's so much i mean part of
the reason why i think it makes sense
for
religious people
christians jews and
islamic alike to focus on
their commonalities in the face of the
things that are disintegrating our
cultures
we could start by trying to make some
peace between us if we're going to
consort ourselves reasonably as
religious individuals
right and i commend you for trying to
to do some bridge building because
uh you know arguably
um
there there's been so much negativity
around this faith and around its
adherence
that there's an almost instantaneous um
association with the most negative
aspects of humanity with the religion
and and it's it's quite tragic and so
just as an exercise a kind of
bracketing for a second and try to try
to think about things uh a mentor of
mine and a friend of mine dr thomas
cleary wrote a book called zen koans he
also translated the quran he's one of
the brilliant translators of the of of
our lifetime
but he wrote a book called zen koans and
in the introduction of that book he
actually says
that the purpose of a koan is to snap
people out of of of selection
yeah
but he says in there but you don't need
a co-on to do that just ask an educated
western person what they think about
islam and they'll start expressing all
of these prejudices and if you ask them
have you ever read the quran no do you
know anything about the prophet muhammad
no
other than maybe something they read in
a a newspaper article or in time or
newsweek or the atlantic monthly
something yeah well it's not it's not an
easy thing to try to get a toehold in a
different tradition especially it's not
that i don't even have a toehold in your
own
yeah i it's not that hard especially for
an educated person you're obviously a
highly educated person it's not that
hard islam one of the things given said
is that islam spread because it's it was
a very easy religion to understand so
this idea that i can't understand it i
can't
i'm having a hard time it's not that
hard to understand
i mean islam is actually a very
straightforward okay then give me a give
me a
five minute
summary of the core beliefs
i i don't want to put you on the spot
i'm it's not a question no no no that's
not it's not that's not hard at all so
so lay it out that would be very so
so we have a famous hadith in which
uh
we're we're told that the
angel gabriel came in the form of a man
and asked the prophet tell me about
faith
and and the prophet muhammad said faith
is to believe that there's only one god
and that muhammad which includes all the
previous messengers is a messenger of
god
to believe in angels to believe in the
books that god has revealed
to believe in the last day the day of
judgment and to believe in
the
measuring out of good and evil that good
and evil is part of life
and then he said tell me about islam and
he said islam is that you
make the testimony of faith that you
pray five times a day that you fast
ramadan that you pay zakat
the 2.5 of your standing wealth at the
end not your income tax but your
standing wealth at the end of the year
that's a whole year 2.140 is given to
poor people there's eight categories
that are given in the quran
and that you if you're able to you make
a pilgrimage once in your lifetime to
mecca and then he said tell me about
ichsan
which is the third dimension of islam
and he said and this is the dimension of
virtuous being by being a person of
erity of excellence in the world
and he said
is to worship god as if you see god
and if you and if you don't see him at
least you know that he sees you so you
have an awareness
of that that that you're that there is a
divine presence
and you should be in a state of
awareness in your behavior i mean one of
the things about
you know if you're driving and
everybody's speeding and then somebody
sees a cop they all suddenly slow down
you know i have a friend once who
just zoomed past the cop when everybody
slowed down and he pulled him over
and he said why didn't you slow down he
said i felt like a hypocrite
so the guy
he let him go
but you know that's people when they're
in the presence of authority they tend
to behave well
unless they're an utter rebel i mean
there are those people
i'm trying to figure out
how to be a jew and a christian and a
muslim at the same time
but become muslim that's the best way
because the beauty of islam is you get
the old testament the new testament the
last testament i mean that really is
for me
even the jews acknowledge this because
islam in many ways is a universalized
judaism it's judaism for the gentiles
uh we we have the mikvah you know they
do hustle we have will soul i mean you
know which is the ritual uh the the
baptism a total immersion in water
ritually to to purify yourself which is
done at least once a week
and uh okay so let me ask you maybe i'll
ask you because we're gonna run out of
time i want to ask you a final question
then you can
maybe help me in my aim
i've been
trying to understand the christian
doctrine of the word and its
relationship to the jewish prophetic
tradition for a long time and i know
that
christ is a central figure
in islam as well
i mean the christians make the claim
that
christ is the son of god right he's the
messiah himself and
it's very difficult if you're going to
be a christian
not to accept that claim and i think i
understand the claim in some sense
psychologically
and i think the notion that
the free word
the free truthful word is the
fundamental redeeming force i believe
that's true i think it's true literally
and i think it's true metaphorically and
i suspect it might be true religiously
although i'm not exactly sure what that
means and i think part of the stumbling
block for me in relationship to islam i
can understand christianity in
relationship to judaism but i can't
understand islam in relationship to
christ
because i
i understand the christian idea that
christ was a what would you say
a transcendent
consequence of the prophetic tradition
and the christian insistence that his
life is associated with the divinity of
the word and that that is in some sense
a final statement and so i don't
understand
how islam moves beyond that
and still places christ in a place of
centrality
well
i mean the jews don't accept christ at
all like the the best of the jews will
say he was a rabbi
but many of the rabbis considered him to
be a charlatan a a magician and and
jesus in the talmud is which was printed
by princeton university press you know
makes makes that argument that the
talmudic
um
uh
views of christ which he he argues in
that book that was understandable given
that the jews were so persecuted by the
christians
but um
the the muslim theology
is
is a
i think it's it's a radical monotheism
that that even i think it transcends the
monthism of uh judaism which has some
anthropomorphic elements in it that
the muslims would not accept
but generally the jews and the
christians agree on the theology
rabbis i've had many talks with rabbis
and
and they they see islam
in fact kohler says that muslims were
always seen as full proselytes of the
noahidic laws whereas christians were
not because of the trinity
so the trinity is you know the the
principle of the triad is uh you know in
plato and the timaeus talks about that
so the principle the triad is very
powerful principle and there are many
many
um trinities in the world that we see so
i don't know i don't understand exactly
why that constitutes such a stumbling
block
i mean
again i'm trying to speak at least to
some degree psychologically
well if you if you read uh-huh
well sorry
it seems to me that the idea of the holy
ghost is allied with the idea of
conscience
you know that voice that speaks from
within
and then the idea of the
sun element of the trinity that's
the fact that divinity can reveal itself
within a personality
well i think and then the idea of god
it's himself the god the father that
seems to me to be the idea that's more
most tightly associated with the jewish
idea of the absolute and the islamic
idea of allah
well i don't think so because uh if you
read meister eckhart or even aquinas on
trinity you know
but eckhart the godhead
you know is is
infinite
cannot be embodied
uh is simple there's no parts
so i think if you get into deep catholic
theology you'll find that in the end it
is a type of unity so the personas and
they are called personas in latin
means mask in latin
it's a mask right and so for for muslims
uh christ is a central figure and
muslims do believe in a second coming of
christ
uh
born of the virgin birth but christ is
not divine christ is human and and
you'll find that in the dual nature not
in the monophysit or the diaphysis
traditions of christianity that you find
like in coptic christianity and some of
the monophysites that believed in that
christ was purely divine but
in this idea that christ is of a dual
nature so the logos in hears and that's
a mystery but i don't i this idea i
catholics never said call like
evangelicals they don't call on christ
as you know when they pray they call on
on god
the father through an intercession of
christ
which is i think
very different from worshipping christ
as
the godhead
um because and and i think it becomes
very confusing even for i think it is i
think it is confusing and and the fact
that it
is one of the stumbling blocks to
something approximating a union of the
great abrahamic traditions is quite a
problem
and well we can agree on a lot of things
i mean we certainly agree on we agree
that there is a god that he created us
we agree that the prophets were sent to
warn people and to give them good news
and we agree that there's a day of
judgment and people are going to be
resurrected
i mean we those are some pretty strong
things to to base uh
a sense of shared concern on we
certainly agree on family we agree on
the importance of raising children
healthy we all share the liberal arts
tradition muslims christians and jews
all share the tradition of the liberal
arts which is well maybe
maybe we could start
in our efforts to move forward by
concentrating on those things that unite
us
well also virtue like virtue ethics i
mean right all three of our religions
share virtue ethics all three and we all
really acknowledge
and and really have benefited greatly
from the nicomachean ethics all three
traditions recognize the nicomachean
ethics and its importance
and that's why our ethical tradition our
great treatises
reflect many of the truths that
aristotle articulated
in the nicomachean ethics
well i think we should probably
call that a day i would like to keep
talking to you
i think it's very useful to outline i
think it was very useful to outline the
central tenets of islamic faith i think
it's very useful to
begin a re-conceptualization in some
sense in the intellectual sphere
that
it might be useful for all the people of
the abrahamic traditions to recognize
their similarities moving forward rather
than concentrating on their differences
i mean we could we could start by
assuming that perhaps our differences
are in some sense apparent and a
consequence of our ignorance
you know what i mean it's not like any
of us can claim to be omniscient
interpreters even of our own faith
tradition
and so we could say well there's a lot
of confusion that reigns and that
disunites us and
we'll be a little careful about making
any authoritarian authoritative claims
on behalf of our own faith
and and see
because we need to figure out how
to tolerate each other and to appreciate
each other and i also think
the disunion between judaism
christianity and islam is also one of
the sicknesses that besets the west
the fact that that disunity exists
makes it more difficult for people who
are searching for
something akin to a tradition to believe
that there's something solid there
because even those who are staunch
adherents of their own traditions don't
seem to be able to get along with those
who are staunch traditions holders of
others
so
anyways discussions like this are some
markers on the pathway to peace let's
say there's a we have an important
tradition from our prophet that says
woe unto those who arrogate to
themselves the judgment of god
yeah that's for sure
and
and and he was asked how do they do that
and he said by saying these people are
in hell and these people are in paradise
you know so that's something
no muslim is permitted to death like i
could never say you're going to hell or
i mean some people do that but it's it's
absolutely prohibited in the islamic
tradition yeah well the problem with
making a judgment like that is it's
pretty easily turned upon yourself
well exactly
it was really good of you to talk to me
today i appreciate it very
much all right
um i have a message here
my my uh
my camera person who set this up just
put a little message he wanted me to
mention the hadith of the prophet in
which he said none of you will enter
paradise by your actions but by the
grace of god alone
so
we need deeds but in the end
we're justified through grace
thank you very much i hope we get a
chance to speak again where are you
located
i'm in berkeley ground zero for the
dissolution of
the western civilization
yeah mm-hmm
i'm coming to california
in uh very soon
maybe i'll see if you'd like to come
well if you do yeah
sure and and come visit the college you
know we have a small liberal arts
college
um
and uh
you know we're we're trying to uh revive
a
tradition that's fallen on hard times in
both the west and the east but it's an
important tradition and it's the
greatest bulwark against
a lot of the things that we're up
against because it really does
teach people to
to
discern between real and apparent goods
well good luck in that endeavor truly
thank you yeah
thank you
take care